so you managed to take the plunge you'll
start plummeting at about 10
m/s and every second after that it gets
faster if we take terminal velocity out
of the mix and assume you weigh 80 kg
you'd eventually reach a speed of 490
m/s so as you fall deeper and deeper
what would happen to your
body falling at such height speed you'll
start to notice things getting a little
toasty as your heart rate starts to
elevate and panic sets in you might find
it getting a little harder to breathe
why well at 150 M down your poor lungs
would be getting crushed by the
constantly increasing air pressure you
might also encounter what cave explorers
like to call foul air deadly underground
pockets of carbon dioxide great